Your University,
your online university.
You and I spoke about that yesterday a bit and you were telling me that the
modules,
um,
are in place or are sort of impressed.
We're starting to design,
well we've,
I can tell you some of the guiding principles of the,
it's the first thing we did was lay out a set of principles that the university
will operate under.
So we want to,
right now it costs about $50,000 a year per student,
which I think is about 10 times more expensive than it should be.
So we want to cut the price.
We want to cut the price by probably a factor of 10 and hopefully a factor of
50.
We want to make the humanities education and science education universally
except accessible.
We want to distribute,
we want to make it an open source university in some sense so that there's no
centralized administration.
We're going to put it outside of the reach of administrators and probably
outside of the reach of the regulations that are credit universities in general
because we're going to set up our own accreditation system.
So we want to operate completely independently of the traditional university
environment and we're going to make it a truly internet university.
It's not going to be lectures and multiple choice questions.
We want to take advantage of the technology.
So the first module we're designing and we want to teach people to write,
speak and think that's,
that's the goals as well as to familiarize themselves with the treasures of the
past,
let's say.
So the first thing we've designed is a writing module.
We're going to release it in modules so that we can test them against the
potential market.
Instead of,
you know,
designing the whole university and launching it.
We don't want to do that.
We want to do it piece by piece.
The first thing we're going to do is to set up a system,
little enabled people to,
to leaf through paragraphs of from different topics.
So there'll be listed by topics so that you can find a paragraph pertaining to
some philosophical or scientific issue that's or literary issue that strikes
your interest.
And then you'll have a chance to write a summary of it,
to rewrite it or to write a commentary on it,
then to vote on other people's summaries,
commentaries or rewrites.
Um,
so that there'll be,
there'll be a competition for writing of the highest quality and so that all of
the topics can be expanded and annotated and so,
and we'll use crowd
the crowd intelligence essentially to,
to,
to do the evaluations.
So that will be distributed as well.
And then your,
your accreditation points will be dependent on how well you're evaluated
essentially by your peers.
And we'll,
we'll give people more voting power as they progress through the courses so that
when you first start and you haven't taken any courses,
then you're voting power will be very restricted.
But as you take more and more courses and become more and more qualified,
then the power of your vote will improve.
So those are some of the ideas so far.
Yeah.
I know all my professors,
you still lament the fact that students couldn't write and they would complain
about this religiously,
that the writing standard of essays and research papers,
they said it was atrocious,
atrocious,
atrocious.
I've had in my fourth year seminar,
I have 20 kids.
Basically,
they're pretty damn bright because it's hard to get into psychology owners.
It's an honor seminar.
It's hard to get into psychology honors.
They're hardworking kids.
Um,
they're devoted to those classes
and they can't.
When the first test,
I have them write the same essay four times,
it gets a first time,
it's four pages,
then it's six pages,
then it's eight pages.
I think that's maybe it's three times and each time I provide them with a lot of
feedback,
tear terror,
their papers apart.
The first papers are so bad that they're actually,
I would say physically painful,
degrade choices,
bad.
The words aren't integrated properly into the sentences.
The sentences aren't organized properly into paragraphs.
The paragraphs aren't sequenced properly.
The essay isn't coherent.
There are there,
I would say they're terrible.
They really deserve 70% of them likely deserve an f.
Now what happens is that I only,
the first essay is only worth 5% so I could just slash it to death without
hurting their chances for a decent grade in the course.
By the second essay,
things have improved quite a lot and by,
I think I do do it four times by the third and the fourth by the fourth essay,
and that's the only one semester the students are writing,
well,
first of all,
the best essays they've ever read,
they all tell me that and essays that are in comparatively better to the ones
that they had started with,
and it's really sad because it shows that they have never been taught to write
despite the fact that they're very bright and now they have 16 years of
education,
they've never been taught to write.
So we really want to solve that problem and we want to make people into
effective speakers and effective thinkers and that'll be about a five year
project,
but it's well underway.
I got two people working on it now we're sketching out the modules.
I'm going to devote a lot of time and resources to it over the next well into
the foreseeable future because it's a really exciting project.